well people often try to avoid ads on tv
or online throughout the year the super
bowl is really one of those only moments
where people actually want to watch the
ads they in some ways even if you're not
a sports fan you tune in to see what the
ads are going to be
there are a lot of brands that appear in
the super bowl every year you've got
your beer brands like anheuser-busch
products you've got your your chips like
friday and doritos and cheetos you've
got your car brands you've got gm and
other brands that always show up but
then every year you've also got some
newcomers which often point to some of
the industries that are trying to get
attention from mainstream audiences this
year you've got wallbox which is an ev
charging station you've got booking.com
which is doing its first super bowl ad
as the travel industry tries to reboot
after two years of people not traveling
as much during the pandemic this year's
super bowl will also include ads from
two different crypto companies ftx
encrypted.com which are both big names
in the cryptocurrency world are running
ads for the first time and it's also
interesting too because both of these
brands have been making major plays at
sports across the board i mean they're
buying up stadium right they're buying
up logo patches and they're trying to
get over you know to that mainstream
audience and far beyond the maybe your
earlier crypto adopters
we don't know how much this year's super
bowl brought in terms of overall ad
revenue but kantar which tracks all this
ad spend said that last year super bowl
55 brought in more than a half a billion
dollars in in-game ad revenue and that
was if you add together the nearly 100
local and national spots that ran during
the game and added up to about almost an
hour of advertising yeah super bowl it's
unique in that it is a time of year when
people want to see ads they're really
captivated by commercials i think that's
pretty unique that doesn't really happen
in any other point in the year
and so it's a great way to spread your
message it's a great way to reach a new
audience especially with the regional
spots you can be very focused very
tactical about where you make sure the
ad shows up well advertising real estate
in the super bowl every year is some of
the most expensive you're gonna find
anywhere this year actually nbc said
that had a new record with several ads
going for seven million dollars you know
it used to be that
you were you know going all in on this
one commercial for this one you know big
day and that's just not the case anymore
we had three teasers leading up to the
super bowl to kind of introduce you to
our characters we have the 60 second
spot that'll be on the game then we cut
that down to 30s 15s and sixes that will
you know be streamed and running social
so you've gotta have a killer you know
mobile idea that extends your whole
platform
each year of the super bowl is one of
the most watched events in in the
country and even if you're not a
football fan or your team's not in the
game people show up to watch the ads
because brands tend to go all out when
it comes to super bowl they want to see
how they can be entertained through
something other than sports you know
every year is a new challenge
and as you know we start this process
the first thing we do in this process is
say what did we learn
from what we've just done what worked
what didn't what inspired us we look at
everyone who's advertised in the game
and we start there that's the beginning
of the process but we're always thinking
about how do we learn and how do we get
better and so we put a lot of
expectation on ourselves because we
really want to show up for our fans in
the best possible way
[Music]